pour une fois c'est le coupable lui même
qui enquêtent trouve et avoue ses
méfaits c'est assez rare pour être
souligné alors ericsson aurait
certainement préféré taire toute la
sphère et c'est surtout sous la pression
des médias suédois qu'ils ont enquêté de
leur côté que le patron du groupe est
passé aux aveux ce mardi en résumé
l'équipementier télécoms a lancé une
enquête interne il y a deux ans sur la
conduite de ses activités entre 2011 et
2010 9 en irak ericsson il dispose d'un
bureau à bagdad et a par exemple
récemment étendu ses partenariats pour
moderniser le réseau sans fil du pays et
certains salariés ou fournisseurs du
groupe ont visiblement pris quelques
libertés avec la loi l'enquète a permis
d'identifier des preuves de mauvaise
conduite liée à la corruption a constaté
des violations des contrôles financiers
internes d'ericsson des conflits
d'intérêts le non respect des lois
fiscales et une obstruction à lenquête
et ça c'est le moins grave parce que
souvenez vous entre 2014 et 2016
principalement une partie du territoire
irakien se trouve sous la coupe de dash
et à ce moment là le seul choix qui
reste à de nombreuses entreprises
étrangères est le suivant quitter le
pays et abandonné leur activité ou
s'arranger avec l'organisation était
hystérique et les employés d'ericsson en
irak semble avoir penché pour la seconde
option l'équipe d' enquête a également
identifié des paiements à des
intermédiaires et l'utilisation
d'itinéraires de transports alternatifs
pour contourner les douanes irakienne à
une époque où des organisations
terroristes dont des shs contrôler
certains itinéraires de transport des
schémas de paiement et des transactions
en espèces constituant potentiellement
un risque de blanchiment d'argent ont
également été identifiés alors ericsson
déclare ne pas être encore parvenus à
déterminer où cet argent a finalement
fini sa course très probablement pour
partie dans les coffres de
l'organisation état islamique ainsi que
le voulaient les us et coutumes de
l'époque c'est notamment ce qu'il s'est
passé avec lafarge dans le pays voisin
le cimentier est en effet soupçonné
d'avoir versé 13 millions d'euros à des
groupes terroristes en syrie entre 2013
et 2014 pour y maintenir ses activités
d'ailleurs le montant des bakchichs
versé par ericsson aux intermédiaires
irakien n'a pas été communiquée par le
groupe suédois on ne sait donc pas s'il
s'agit de 1000 ou 2 millions d'euros
cela dit quelle que soit la somme la
réputation de l'équipement tir n'a pris
un coup le titre du suédois a chuté de
plus de 14% en 24 heures à la suite des
révélations de son pdg ce qui a fait
s'envoler du même coup plusieurs
milliards d'euros de capitalisation et
oui cette fois ci la faute avouée n'a
pas du tout été pardonné